Це професія, якій потрібно
присвятити, дійсно, все своє життя.
Якщо ти дійсно хочеш досягти успіху,
то він не буде обмежуватися
діяльністю в одній країні.
Потрібно завоювати кращі сцени цілого світу.
[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]
[Дюссельдорф,
Німеччина]
Жінки за пультом великих симфонічних
оркестрів до сих пір є унікальним явищем.
Навіть для Європи.
Я — Оксана Линів, диригентка.
Народилася в Україні,
зараз живу в Німеччині,
а працюю по всьому світі.
Я народилася і виросла в музичній родині.
[Оксана Линів
диригентка]
Мої обидвоє батьків — і мама, і батько
— є музикантами і педагогами.
Мій дідо по батьковій лінії
був також хоровим диригентом.
Тобто, вийшло так, що я — вже третє
покоління диригента в нашій родині
і для мене ніколи не стояло
питання вибору професії.
З трьох років я була свідома того,
що я обов'язково хочу бути на сцені,
я не хотіла бути вчителькою музики,
як моя мама.
Я хотіла обов'язково бути на сцені,
але точно не знала, в якій ролі.
Моцарт відіграв у моєму житті
особливу роль.
Я, фактично, заради Моцарта
їхала в Німеччину —
мені хотілось дійсно
вивчити цей стиль.
Я розуміла, що це якесь особливе мистецтво,
особливий композитор.
Я змінила місце проживання, країну,
місто — для мене все нове.
Тут збоку буде невеличка кухня,
яка зараз вже найбільш обжита,
тому що я вже сюди перевезла
дуже важливу річ для мене
— моя макітра з макогоном,
яку я купила під час свого
першого переїзду — це був 2005 рік, —
коли я поїхала в Німеччину.
І вишиваний обрус, який
застеляється на кожне свято.
Сама я народилася в невеличкому
місті Броди, 100 км від Львова.
У нас дуже гарний власний будинок
з надзвичайно великим садом
і моє улюблене місце для творчості
завжди було
знайти якесь затишне місце,
щоб можна було дивитися на небо, слухати
пташок, слухати музику, вивчати партитури.
Музика — це не те, що записано в нотах.
Музика — це те, що стоїть поза нотами.
І розшифрувати, дізнатися все про твір,
про композитора, про його стиль
дійсно потребує дуже багато часу,
дуже багато роботи
і величезного досвіду роботи.
Ось з цієї книги почався
цілий фестиваль LvivMozArt.
Фестиваль LvivMozArt був заснований,
насправді, з великою просвітницькою метою.
По-перше, розповісти про Україну в світі.
По-друге, розповісти про
історичний зв'язок України
з великою європейською
культурною традицією,
але також, щоб поряд з відомими
композиціями видатних класиків світу
прозвучали твори українських композиторів.
Власне, сам факт того, що Франц
Ксавер Моцарт — ось цей, молодший,
у Львові прожив майже 30 років,
жив, працював як піаніст, як педагог,
заснував хорове Товариство Святої Цецилії,
яке дало початок професійній
музичній діяльності у Львові
і потім вже переросло в Галицьке
музичне товариство.
І філармонія, і створення
Вищого музичного інституту,
зараз музичної академії, консерваторії
— це все було похідним від того,
що почав Франц Ксавер Моцарт.
Одним з пам'ятних моментів, які мене тут
вразили, є, по-перше, його листи зі Львова.
По-друге, спогад про те,
як він виконував «Реквієм»
свого батька Вольфганга Амадея Моцарта
у Церкві Юра у Львові.
Про це написали, навіть, віденські газети.
Традиція виконувати «Реквієм» до пам'яті,
посмертної дати
Вольфганга Амадея Моцарта, у Львові
випередила на 15 років навіть
віденську традицію.
Чому? Тому що єдиний живий син
і музикант Франц Ксавер Моцарт
приїхав до Львова і там зупинився.
Чому він зупинився у Львові на 30 років?
Він закохався у відому львівську графиню
Жозефіну фон Кавалькабо,
яка була дружиною першого радника
львівського бургомістра,
у неї було двоє доньок.
І, власне, Франц Ксавер Моцарт
на ціле життя став учителем музики.
Є лист, де Франц Ксавер
говорить своєму другу,
що на зворотній адресі не потрібно
вказувати ніякої вулиці.
«Пиши просто — Моцарту, тому що кожен
львів'янин знає, де живе Моцарт».
А я подумала про те, чи знає зараз
кожен львів'янин, що тут дійсно жив Моцарт?
Бути справжнім артистом — означає
присвятити своє життя мистецтву
і завжди, коли ти себе
чомусь повністю присвячуєш,
це значить, що ти відрікаєшся чи
відмовляєшся від якихось інших речей.
Тут теж гарно.
Ще тут є вихід в сад
і величезна шафа,
що дуже добре.
Я ще не почала нічого розкладати,
але це один з моїх концертних костюмів.
Всі свої концертні костюми
я замовляю і шию у Львові.
І так вже 20 років.
Для мене це важливо.
Це мої улюблені екземпляри.
Це — борщівська, їх дуже мало,
але це дуже красиво.
Я це вдягаю будь-де — у Відні, в Парижі.
Це завжди унікально виглядає.
У мене їх тут штук, напевно, тридцять
і у Львові ще три скрині.
Дуже багато, насправді.
В нас робота така, що ти кожних
3-5 років в іншій країні.
І психологічно для мене було дуже важливо
кинути свій якір, знати, де я є постійно.
І я дуже рада, що в мене у Львові
також є своє помешкання,
куди я постійно приїжджаю, повертаюся.
Там стоїть моє фортепіяно, на якому
я починала колись вчитися музиці,
і яке купував ще колись
мій дідо для моєї мами.
Тобто такі, дійсно, мої речі, реліквії,
і для мене дуже важливо
мати таке своє місце.
Зараз, відколи успішно
розвивається моя кар'єра,
я отримую численні запрошення
дуже відомих колективів.
Фактично, дуже часто відбувається так, що я чую,
що «Ви знаєте, що ви — перша жінка,
хто виступає, наприклад,
у німецькій опері Берліна?»
чи «Ви знаєте, що ви — перша жінка
за пультом цього оркестру?»,
«Ви знаєте, що ви — перша жінка,
яка диригує Вагнера в Іспанії?».
І, дійсно, до сих пір так є, що відсоток
успішних жінок-диригентів у світі,
які керують відомими колективами,
— це три відсотки зі ста.
Ми в Україні ніяк не стимулюємо,
по-перше, створення нових творів
молодими українськими композиторами,
по-друге, не вивчаємо і не досліджуємо те,
що є і те, що вже було написано.
Завжди популяризацією своєї власної культури
займається сама держава, в першу чергу.
Немає навіть виданих нот українських класиків.
У більшості випадків ноти українських класиків,
як, навіть, наприклад, Бориса Лятошинського,
не були ніколи виданими,
не були ніколи впорядкованими.
Тому ми не можемо вимагати від німців,
що вони нічого не знають про нас,
якщо ми це не знаємо, не досліджуємо
і не виконуємо на такому рівні,
який ми також могли би
презентувати на весь світ.
Я мала змогу навчатися
в двох навчальних закладах:
в Україні в Львівській музичній академії,
а також у Дрезденській Вищій музичній школі.
Я можу сказати, що якби
я не отримала базу в Україні,
я не змогла би досягти того успіху,
який я зараз маю,
тому що в Німеччині я, фактично,
вже могла шліфувати свої знання.
Ще одна сторінка і ще один величезний
і важливий для мене проєкт,
моя гордість, але і велика-велика робота,
моя ініціятива — це створення молодіжного
симфонічного оркестру України.
[Львів,
Галичина]
Створення такого оркестру було
моєю великою і дуже давньою мрією.
Я згадувала, як колись, ще студенткою, у мене
не було ніяких перспектив і можливостей,
незважаючи на мої дані і талант,
і бажання, і те, що я тим горіла.
Мені дуже захотілося дати
наступному поколінню, молоді, цей шанс.
Коли я бачу очі цих дітей, які...
Я зараз розповідаю
і мені самій мороз по шкірі,
тому що, наприклад, в Берліні
на фестиваль Young Euro Classic,
найбільший фестиваль
молодіжних оркестрів світу,
нас не хотіли запрошувати.
Тому що фестиваль проходив 2018-го року,
а оркестр заснований з 2017-го,
тобто оркестру тільки один рік.
І коли ми до них звернулися,
— а там є велике російське лоббі —
вони сказали,
що українській молодіжний оркестр — ні,
давайте почекаємо трошки,
ми поспостерігаємо, подивимось,
що ви можете,
на якому ви рівні будете грати,
тому що ця стена, Konzerthouse Berlin,
є занадто престижною для колективу,
який існує всього рік.
Я доклала дуже багато зусиль
і заявила дуже серйозну програму.
Крім творів українських композиторів,
ще Симфонію № 7 Бетховена,
яка вважається за пробний камінь
навіть для дорослих колективів.
Ми приїжджаємо в Берлін і цю програму
ми до того не мали змоги обіграти ніде.
І це діти, які тільки на декілька тижнів
приїхали з усіх куточків України,
і вони всі різного віку —
від 14 років до 22, старших немає.
І, насправді, вони вперше сидять разом
в одному колективі на такій престижній сцені
і вони повинні при повному залі публіки
в Берліні, в серці Німеччини,
виконати симфонію німецького автора,
переконати, заявити себе.
І вийшло так, що мені довелося
перед концертом всіх добре налаштувати,
що це як молодіжна олімпійська збірна,
тільки не в спорті, а в мистецтві, у музиці,
що від цього виступу залежать
наші подальші перспективи.
І вони дійсно дуже налаштувалися.
І коли після фіналу Бетховена
переповнений зал Кonzerthaus Berlin
встав і зробив нам 17-хвилинні
стоячі овації, аплодували цим дітям.
І подивитися на їхні очі — вони стояли,
не розуміли, що це робиться,
тому що аплодисменти —
наскільки Бетховен написав
гучну і могутню музику —
аплодисменти були у декілька
разів гучнішими і не змовкали.
Це настільки важливо
усвідомити нам, українцям,
починаючи від рівня
держави до наших громадян,
яке значення має культура.
Ми не можемо порівняти, чому
весь світ захоплюється Моцартом, Бахом.
Ми повинні зрозуміти значення і різницю
між популярною культурою, естрадою,
яка створює настрій,
під яку дуже приємно відпочивати,
це все розваги, те, чому ми можемо
приділяти увагу кожен день,
але це все не буде мати абсолютно ніякого
значення в перспективі ста років.
Кожен повинен займатися тим,
чим він може займатися найкраще,
— в цьому полягає сенс життя.
І, звичайно, що моє слово
є на сцені, моє слово є в музиці,
у моїх найбільш важливих проєктах.
І мені дуже хочеться, щоб в Україні
і уряд очолювали професіонали
з найвищим рівнем відповідальності,
які здатні планувати
і зробити вклад і вплив на
історію розвитку нашої держави
в перспективі наступних сотень років.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Інтерв'юерка
Ольга Войтович]
[Режисери
Микола Носок, Василь Гошовський]
[Режисери монтажу
Ліза Літвіненко, Дмитро Бартош]
[Оператори
Анна Савчук, Павло Пашко,
Сергій Коровайний,
Тарас Мучичка, Сергій Донських,
Омелян Ощудляк, Юрій Данкевич]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Катерина Акварельна,
Наталія Панченко]
[Асистентки продюсерки
Ксенія Фукс, Євгенія Лисак]
[Звукорежисерка
Анастасія Климова]
[Субтитрувальниця
Діна Безсмертна]
[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]